desde que tengo uso de razón todo lo que
he hecho ha sido dibujar dibujar porque
es lo que más me hace feliz en el mundo
de hecho cada vez que hago una obra soy
tan feliz que un poco que todas las
personas que vean la obra puedan por al
menos por unos segundos sentir la misma
felicidad que yo siento cuando estoy
igual
cuando tenía seis años todo lo que hacía
era dibujar en las paredes los cuadernos
del trabajo de mi mamá en las hojas que
yo conseguían todos lados así que mi ama
decidió inscribirme en un curso de
dibujo que se impartía cerca de la casa
donde bueno me deben enseñar perspectiva
anatomía proporciones todo lo que yo
necesitaba para ser un gran artista
sin embargo en este curso donde me están
enseñando todo esto tan importante yo
solamente dure dos semanas porque si
bien está aprendiendo todas estas
técnicas sumamente valiosas lo único que
yo quería aprender era dibujar mejor al
hombre araña
[Música]
y bueno no lo estaban enseñando muy bien
como pueden ver así que dejó de asistir
a este curso de dibujo y sigo dibujando
por mi cuenta a los 14 años empiezo a
dibujar sobre un tema que muy pocas
personas habían tratado que era el
fútbol nacional venezolano porque sobre
todo es decir quién iba a dibujar de
fútbol venezolano cuando venezuela no
hay domingo mundial no ha ganado nada
importante esto no te lleva a ser rico
ni famoso pero yo no quería ser rico y
famoso yo tenía 14 años yo lo que quería
era dibujar a mis jugadores favoritos
dibujar lo que yo veía en la cancha que
quería dibujar los jugadores de la
selección nacional que notaban los goles
para la vinotinto y esto bueno a pesar
de todos los errores que pueden tener
porque me salía el curso de dibujo
obviamente
era la primera vez que un fanático del
fútbol en venezuela veía su pasión en
una ilustración y se empezó a viralizar
en las redes sociales mientras que yo
por mi parte contactaban medios
deportivos prensa radio televisión pero
todos me decían mira chavo tiene apenas
14 años está haciendo los garabatos mira
no podemos hacer mucho por ti
pero de tanto insistir en las redes
logró una entrevista en un sitio web
llamaba lavinotinto.com yo voy a esta
entrevista con mi mamá 15 años y recién
cumplido hoy con el uniforme el colegio
incluso y cuando llegó a la entrevista
el director juan carlos rutilo sale y
dice bueno dónde está el señor oscar
olivares
yo mira señor no pero yo mismo soy pero
que esto le puede dar a pesar de eso él
decide porque yo no podía me da ningún
correo para que me tomarán en serio él
decide confiar en mí me contrata como el
primer caricaturista del fútbol nacional
debutando cuando le ganamos 10 argentina
en puerto la cruz y una en el momento
más feliz de mi vida imagine me iban a
pagar por dibujar a mis ídolos algo que
yo hacía porque prácticamente para jugar
para divertirme me iban a pagar por eso
estaba ganando la vinotinto
pero en este momento tan feliz surgen en
las redes un grupo de haters personas
que decían que es una vergüenza para el
fútbol venezolano que como le podían
pagar un chavito a un muchacho de 15
años por un trabajo gran mal hecho
ellos me hicieron entender que la única
manera de hacer algo relevante
importante en el mundo es estudiando es
preparándose desarrollando los talentos
que tenemos porque todas las personas en
el mundo tienen un don tienen un talento
y quienes dicen no chavo tuvieron un
talento pero yo soy normal normal todos
tenemos un talento y quienes dicen que
no lo tienen es porque no se han
atrevido a conocerse a sí mismos para
descubrir los talentos que tienen porque
conocernos a nosotros mismos significa
descubrir nuestra identidad más allá de
los países nuestra identidad en la luz y
en la oscuridad salir de la zona de
confort
a lo mejor abandonar ese trabajo que no
nos gusta y dedicarnos a nuestra
verdadera pasión que nos va a llevar a
nuestro potencial más grande en el
planeta tierra
yo no podía darme el lujo de esperar a
graduarme del colegio porque mis dibujos
ya estaban siendo expuestos así que
mientras estaba estudiando física
química matemática tiene que buscar cómo
mejorar mis trabajos y así en unos dos
años
mejoraron de esta manera los dibujos el
rostro de juan arango y lo más
importante es que yo aprendí a dibujar
mejor al hombre el año por supuesto
en este año 2013 donde ya dibujaba mejor
al hombre araña
yo realmente sabía que todos los dibujos
de fútbol iban a ser un éxito eran
virales pero tenía que salir de la zona
de confort así que le dije a mi mamá que
yo quería exponer en la caracas cómico
un evento que se hace bueno la
convención de cómics más importante de
venezuela y yo le dije mamá yo quiero
exponer para mostrarme un público
distinto salir de la zona de conformidad
mostrarme otra gente pero la verdadera
intención que yo tenía con ir a la
comicon era vender suficientes mis
dibujos como para poder comprar un
playstation
porque yo nunca había tenido un
playstation mi mamá decía que ya no me
lo compraba para que pusiera dibujar no
sé si era verdad pero bueno resultó el
caso es que si yo quería el playstation
tenía que ganarme no soy yo en peso en
playstation3 usados de gastar el
playstation 4 entonces empieza a hacer
caricaturas de toda la gente en la
comic-con hago más de 100 caricaturas
que yo no podía más con la mano de
tantos dibujos que yo había hecho tiene
que ir al baño de agua fría web y tenía
el dinero para comprarme el playstation
el amigo del colegio voy a comprar iba a
comprar su resistencia con eso traía que
si fifa 2005 una cosa si el station pero
iba a pasar algo clave que me iba a
impedir comprar
unas semanas después voy saliendo del
colegio camino a mi casa con los amigos
y dos tipos en moto nos asaltan nos
roban los teléfonos pero llego a mi casa
aterrado
entendiendo en ese momento que la vida
no era solamente dibujar su pero en el
fútbol hay entiendo que vivía o que vivo
en la ciudad más insegura del mundo que
es caracas con la situación más crítica
en la historia del país
entiendo que había algo más allá todos
mis amigos el colegio me decían que yo
me iba a morir de hambre siendo artist
esto no tenía ningún futuro en venezuela
que eso era patético que eso no tenía
ningún sentido lo primero que pienso es
irme del país y amo a mi tío que bien
colombiana y combinativo yo me enteré
del país me pasó esto voy a ser un
fracasado si soy artista
pero después pensándolo bien me doy
cuenta de que mi vida no se podía
definir por las cosas malas que me
pasaban o por lo negativo a mi alrededor
sino por lo que yo hacía frente a ese
tipo de situaciones y al ver todos los
superhéroes que me gustaban tanto me di
cuenta de que a todos les pasa algo
crítico antes de encontrar su identidad
y su propósito al hombre araña le matan
a su tío a batman le matan a sus padres
el planeta de superman lo destruyen para
que les venga a la tierra y esto nos lo
han contado desde niños y no nos hemos
dado cuenta
fue ahí cuando entendí que no tenía que
ir a ningún lado que estando en
venezuela podría buscar dibujar un país
mejor y no era que iba a ser un dibujo
ya se soluciona la economía la inflación
la inseguridad no eso no estaba en mis
manos yo no podía vivir solamente
pensando en cosas que no estaban en mis
manos tenía que concentrarme en lo que
sí dependía de mí lo que yo dibujaba
el dinero del playstation se transformó
en una gran biblioteca llena de libros
de conocimiento porque yo no iba a pasar
mi vida jugando este yo tenía que tener
un propósito y ese propósito era ser un
mejor artista y dibujar mejor al hombre
araña
empiezo al año 2014 una serie de
protestas importantes y un día veo en
instagram una foto de un araguaney árbol
el árbol nacional con flores amarillas y
el cielo azul
yo digo hoy ahora bueno y amarillo cielo
azul yo le meto rojo a esto son los
colores de la bandera de venezuela
empecé a investigar en las redes y que
no había absolutamente nada como esta
serie con los colores de la bandera
nacional era algo totalmente innovador
y yo he encontrado esa idea en algo tan
simple como una fotografía en interno
por eso muchas veces decimos que en
venezuela no hay oportunidades yo les
digo que esto es verdad porque las
oportunidades no están en los países
están en las personas de los países en
su inteligencia en sus dones
en sus capacidades
y en lo que hacen frente a las
adversidades
ninguna galería de arte quería mostrar
esto porque yo tenía 17 años tampoco me
tomaban en serio pero me fui a las redes
sociales y hay una obra miren puede
tener más de 25.000 likes picasso no
tenía instagram tenía que esperar que
viniera una persona a ver su obra hoy en
día podemos mostrar nuestros talentos
inmediatamente a miles y millones de
personas esto nos permitió inspirar a
otras personas
llegar a colegios en donde han estudiado
el arte con la bandera los resultados en
google y buscaban arte con la bandera
antes y si lo buscan hoy en día y eso
fue un mito muchacho en su casa
escuchando música dibujando así que
pensamos que alguien que cumple sus
sueños extraordinario pero lo normal es
que sigamos el camino de nuestros sueños
lo extraño debe ser abandonar nuestros
sueños por lo que nos dice la sociedad
por lo que nos dice la gente que nos va
a dar dinero los sueños no se miden por
una cuenta bancaria los sueños se miden
por lo que hay dentro de nosotros por
nuestras capacidades de inteligencia
tuvimos una exposición de obras
terminando empezando el 2015 en la
universidad metropolitana
que en donde se vendieron todas las
obras que los artistas no se mueran de
hambre el año seguro que picasso no se
murió de hambre
y eso abrió las puertas para tener la
primera exposición internacional en
miami en ese mismo año 2015 fue un éxito
total que abrió las puertas para en ese
mismo año ir a bogotá a houston y a
panamá en enero de 2015 yo no tenía como
pagar un pasaje de avión a ningún lado
era el año con más viajes de toda mi
vida como era es imposible en esta
situación con esta economía
porque yo no estaba concentrado en el
pasaje de avión yo estaba concentrado en
crear obras de arte yo no quería viajar
yo quería llevar mi arte a otro nivel
imagínense que yo esté tenido el dinero
del pasaje y no hubiesen tenido las
obras de arte y he sido mucho más
complicado pero al tener las obras de
arte tenía el primer paso
en panamá conocí a el maestro carlos
cruz-diez
quizás el artista más influyente del
siglo 20 venezuela y lo que más me
impactó al conocerlo es ver una persona
que hace unos días cumplió 95 años y
está llena de proyectos de sueños y al
ver que él es un soñador con 95 años me
ponía a pensar y decía
como es posible que el con 95 años está
soñando y que hay jóvenes de 20 que no
están soñando
qué tipo de limitación nos estamos
poniendo porque esa es una limitación
que depende de nosotros del sueño no
puede haber escasez porque esos dependen
solamente del potencial humano
y después de ese encuentro increíble
fuimos a colombia a donde me iba a ir
cuando me asaltaron ahora no iba porque
me asaltaron iba a representar a
venezuela y cada venezolano que estar en
el país debe ser con un propósito
llegamos allá porque fuimos nominados a
los premios iberoamericanos de
emprendimiento online 2015
en donde se postularon más de 200
empresas de todo el continente empresas
con mejor situación económica empresas
con más años en el mercado con más
conocimientos yo tenía un año de haberme
graduado del colegio empresas con más
empleados los únicos empleados éramos mi
mamá y yo más nadie esperamos todos los
empleados que estarán en empresas
y a pesar de todo eso a pesar de tener
todo en contra porque cuando tenemos
todo en contra es que tenemos que dejar
todo en la cancha y este premio se vino
para venezuela como el mejor uso de
redes sociales y como el tercer mejor
emprendimiento e iberoamérica
[Aplausos]
evaluado por más de 40 jurados de todo
el continente
y yo le di gracias a dios por todo por
todo lo que había pasado me di cuenta de
que todo era un hilo perfecto de
situaciones que llevaban a ese punto
clave
agradecía a dios por todo agradecía a
dios por los haters en las redes
sociales que me llevaron a estudiar
agradecía a dios por el asalto porque si
no fuera por el asalto quizás estaría
jugando playstation en mi caso y no
estaría hoy acá con todos ustedes
profundice mi obra gracias a eso
agradecía a dios por las galerías que no
mostraron mi trabajo gracias a eso lo
coloqué en las redes sociales y el
premio el mejor uso de redes sociales
y en ese punto volvía acá
a este primer dibujo que hizo del hombre
araña a los 6 años
unos años después que yo hago este
dibujo yo envía una aplicación una
galería de arte internacional como
enviado como 70
que nunca responde presta respondió y de
sueños premios tus obras a ver qué
podemos hacer radio les envío como 30
obras y cuando les envío estas 30 obras
y me dicen oscar estas cuatro obras
queremos llevarlas al art expo de nueva
york 2017 que es la feria de arte más
grande del mundo con más de 30 mil
personas más de 3.000 expositores más de
mil artistas y aguado y cuáles son las
cuatro obras una de bogotá una de la
torre eiffel una de la amazona y la
cuarta obra y más importante era una del
hombre araña comiéndose una arepa
[Aplausos]
una obra
el departamento jugando la hice por
diversión tiene detalles del caracas fc
tiene detalles de la guerra de las
galaxias' tiene un bolso de la vinotinto
y esa obra que se convirtió es en este
momento mi obra más valiosa en todo el
mundo esta obra nos llevó a la ciudad
del hombre-araña siendo el artista más
joven exponiendo en el expo de nueva
york 2017 de todas las obras que pusimos
se vendió una que fue la del hombre
araña
y por supuesto que a esa exposición yo
me llevé mi primer dibujo
hombre araña primero aprendí a dibujar y
después escribir pues lo primero lo más
importante
pero cuando yo veo
en la exposición de nueva york este
hombre araña que está expuesto
permanentemente en malasia cuando yo veo
esto yo entendí finalmente que estar ahí
en nueva york no era el sueño del
artista plástico oscar olivares estar
ahí en nueva york
era el sueño del niño de 6 años que
abandonó su curso de dibujo porque lo
que ese niño quería era dibujar a su
superhéroe favorito y allí estaba el
niño 14 años después todavía dibujando a
su superhéroe favorito que si pudiera
viajar en el tiempo le diría que se
saliera de su curso de dibujo y que
siguiera haciendo lo que le hace feliz
porque los niños dibujan con un
sentimiento puro y nadie en el mundo te
puede enseñar a tener un sentimiento
puro solo una inspiración que nace del
alma que nace del corazón recuerden
cuando nos rodean tantas cosas que no
funcionan
nosotros podemos crear algo que sí
funcione muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]